الحرب تابى ان تضع اوزارها في السودان
اصوات الرصاص والمدافع ترتفع على الاصوات
التي تنادي بالسلام والحوار الهدى المعلنه
ليست سوى مجرد كلام لا وقف الاطلاق النار
تحقق حتى الان ست هدى خرقت كل طرف يلقي
باللائمه على الاخر الجيش السوداني اصدر
بيانا رمى من خلاله الكره الى ملعب قوات
الدعم السريع متهما اياها بخرق الهدنه
ومواصله القصر العشوائي لبعض المواقع بما
فيها الاحياء السكنيه الموقف العملياتي
ومستقر في جميع انحاء البلاد باستثناء
اشتباكات متقطعه مع الدعم في اجزاء من
العاصمه نتيجه لخروقها المستمره للهدنه
المعلنه
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اعاد الكره الى ملعب
الجيش مشيرا الى ان الدعم السريع لا ترفض
الهدى بل وتقدر جميع مبادره الحل وما زلنا
نحن اليوم نعيش هدنه معلنه
طيران يخطف المدنيين ويخطف مواقعنا
الطرفان يشيران ايضا الى بسط السيطره على
المناطق الحيويه خاصه في العاصمه الخرطوم
مبعوث رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني اكد ان
الوضع الامني تحت سيطره الجيش باستثناء
بعض الجيوب مشيرا الى ان هناك سبعه عشره
ولايه سودانيه من اصل ثماني عشره تحت
سيطره القوات المسلحه حاليا اما قوه الدعم
فقد اعلنت انها تبسط سيطرتها على 99% من
ولايه الخرطوم وتعد بما سمته النصر القريب
الجيش عاد ليتهم الدعم السريع بارتكاب
عمليات نهب وسرقه في الخرطوم مستشار
حميدتي نفى الاتهام واصفا ذلك بغير الصحيح
مسلسل الاتهامات والاتهامات المضاده مستمر
في ظل تواصل الاشتباكات الضاريه بدون افق
لنهايه الازمه حتى الان بلال البجدين
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات